I have been doing reviews of my supporters’
decks for almost two years now, and over that
time I’ve noticed some patterns, some
common stumbling blocks that a lot of
players tend to hit. This isn’t just the
new players either—I’m sampling here from
players who watch my videos and like
them enough to give me money about it,
and that’s to say nothing of the deckbuilding
mistakes I occasionally catch myself making
and need to correct. Having just finished up
a deck review, which you can check out on my
second channel if you’d like, I did the
sort of normal thing you might expect of
me—I went back through every single deck I’ve
ever reviewed, looked at what feedback I gave,
and tallied up the number of each general family
of critique I gave. And, this video is that—the
most common deckbuilding mistakes I see and a
brief discussion of how to avoid each of them.
#5: Your deck is unfocused on the
macro level, or in terms of its goals
This is a piece of feedback I’ve given 7 times
in my reviews, and of these five mistakes this
is the one I see most commonly with newer players.
There are lots of decks that are built around some
central synergy pillar like lifegain or +1/+1
counters or self-discard, and this is a great
place to start when you’re building an EDH deck.
Where the issues start to show up is when a player
builds a deck centered around a specific element,
but doesn’t have any sense of direction for the
rest of their deck. What this usually means in
practice is that somebody has a whole bunch of
different payoffs for a particular mechanic, but
with these payoffs shooting off in a variety of
different directions with no rhyme or reason.
If I’m building a landfall deck and looking for
payoffs, I can add cards that make tokens, cards
that buff my creatures, cards that gain me life,
cards that damage opponents, cards that generate
value, cards that hinder opposing creatures,
and a whole bunch of other tasks that
are much more specific. It is totally
possible that I grab a couple clusters of
cards that end up working well together.
Maybe I pull together token-producing landfall
cards along with landfall cards that buff wide
boards, plus a couple options for ramp, value, and
combat amplification sprinkled on top. However,
it’s easy to imagine this going wrong as
well—maybe I’m starting from the place
of some tokens and buffs but then I add one or two
damaging cards like Tunneling Geopede. Suddenly,
the clarity of my gameplan has been diluted a
little, with incremental damage being played
alongside the big, dramatic swings of the token
beatdown plan, and taking up a slot that could
have helped that token plan more. Now let’s
say I add a card like Grazing Gladehart. Well,
lifegain can be nice for stabilizing a deck that
is slow or light on creatures, and it can also be
good paired with lifegain payoffs. But neither
of those things are going to be true about our
landfall beatdown deck, and adding lifegain just
adds fluff that doesn’t serve our deck’s goals.
Ultimately, this problem will typically be
ironed out in the process of tuning a deck
and figuring out exactly where it wants to be
going. A necessary lesson here is in restraint:
knowing when to exclude a card even when it
theoretically has a bit of synergy with what
you’re building. Part of why this mistake
is especially common among newer players is
because it often takes a bit of card knowledge
to know what might serve a deck’s interests more
than the 18th landfall card or the 13th lifegain
payoff. If you’re cruising through scryfall with
a certain search term related to your synergy
family, it’s easy to just add endlessly until
your deck space has filled up, and this will
create a deck that does something. The trick is
learning to crank up the specificity, and turning
a soup of generic payoffs into a deck that knows
what it is and where it wants to be going. If
this sounds like something you struggle with,
I made two videos last year that both heavily
cover this topic, one about building decks
that win, and one covering decks oriented
around a creature type. Those are in the
description if you want to check them out
a bit later, but for now let’s move on to…
#4: Your deck is vulnerable to opposing hate
I’ve said this about 8 decks in my reviews,
and it’s a classic one. Some decks are a bit
of a glass cannon—they have the potential to be
very powerful, but can easily get kneecapped and
do nothing. There are other decks that simply
have vulnerable gameplans in some way or other
due to having an expensive commander or a gameplan
that invests heavily into a particular resource.
Regardless of the reason, decks whose gameplans
are fragile in some way are common, and it’s good
to mitigate a bit of fragility if doing so doesn’t
have too much of an opportunity cost. The most
popular suggestion here is protection, but this
is where I need to get into a bit of an awkward
confession—I don’t like protection spells very
much. I have a Voltron deck that uses a bunch of
protection cards to decent effect, but I’ve had
multiple other protection-heavy decks that just
felt kinda bad to play. Protection feels great to
have when I’m ahead, but when I’m behind they’re
the most useless pieces of garbage clogging up my
hand that I can possibly imagine. I will happily
accept that this is a me problem, but this is also
my youtube video, so I’m going to tell you about a
bunch of ways to increase a deck’s durability
without adding purpose-made protection spells.
Firstly, some protection spells are useful
outside of protecting a key creature from removal,
my favorite category of which is Counterspells.
There are certainly other examples of this
though—flicker spells like Ghostway can get
a bunch of extra value off of ETB creatures,
and protection-from spells are a form
of evasion. There’s also the boot
equipments that grant both a protective
keyword and haste. Speaking of which,
Haste! The worst feeling is having a creature
eat dirt before it could do anything at all,
but if you have a creature you want to attack with
or activate a tap ability of, giving it haste in
some form or other fully prevents this. Though you
might be thinking “but Alex, I’m a blue player,
I can’t run Anger or Arena of Glory.” You’re
right about that, but what you can run is
Leyline of Anticipation or Alchemist’s Refuge.
Saving your deck’s pivotal setup plays for an
opposing endstep rather than trotting them out
on your main phase dramatically increases the
odds that you’ll actually get to use them, and
effectively increases the amount of mana you get
to spend uninterrupted by opposing main phases.
This brings me to my final suggestion—ramp! If you
have cards that like to be played together but
which cost a lot of mana, you might be tempted
to play one, have it sit around naked out in the
cold for a whole turn cycle before finally playing
the card that synergizes with it. By simply
having more mana you can avoid this issue,
and ramp also works well for bouncing back after
a setback so long as you have cards in hand.
If you like this video so far,
you should smash that like button,
eviscerate that subscribe button, and obliterate
your current state of not giving me a few dollars
by signing up for my patreon, or a YouTube
membership. I made a supporter-only companion
piece to this videos that covers some
deckbuilding mistakes I’ve made this year,
and a preview for that will be at the end
of this video. With that said, let’s get to…
#3: Your deck isn’t proactive enough
I’ve had this piece of critique for 10 decks, and
it’s sort of related to the unfocused goals issue
in the sense that both are concerned with a deck’s
ability to win games, but the types of deck I have
this to say about are quite different from those
decks. When I say a deck isn’t proactive enough,
I’m typically talking about a deck that is already
doing a decent job of managing opposing decks in
some way or other. Maybe it’s a political or
pillowfort deck with tools to keep opposing
creatures away, or maybe it’s a control deck with
lots of removal and counterspells. Regardless,
the issue here is usually that a deck is spending
too much space on this task, and fails to create
its own gameplan. The most common place we see
this is with “goad decks”, which if I’m being
honest is a pair of two words that don’t really
belong together. If you’re adding a goad card to
your deck, its effectiveness will be inversely
proportional to the number of goad cards already
in your deck. The first two or three goad cards
might feel great for redirecting the heat of
opposing creatures, and maybe even the fifth
or sixth one as well depending on what you find
yourself playing against. Much past that, though,
and you’re gonna find yourself drawing multiple
of them, and maybe there isn’t a great thing
to goad in a given moment. Sometimes opponents
will have lots of great things to goad, but other
times there might only be a single key attacker,
with everything else being an anemic little
goober, and in that case you’ve been handed the
decision of either using a goad card suboptimally,
or having it sit in hand doing nothing at all.
With goad in particular, I think part of the
issue is that players treat goad as a plan for
winning in and of itself, when it’s really
not a mechanic that can be relied on to do
that. It can be a plan for softening opponents
a bit, but I prefer to play it safe and treat
goad cards as defensive tools for the early-mid
game that might occasionally come with a bit of
damage and disruption as a side benefit. It’s
easy to overload on something like goad if you
consider it “your plan” but pretend your goad
cards are fogs instead and suddenly your deck
with 12 fogs in it is looking a little suspect.
This ties in with how a deck is categorized—if
you give an effect like goad its own category
in a deckbuilding website like Archidekt,
you’re giving your brain the opportunity to
draw up heuristics anytime you look at your
deck. Even if your conscious mind knows
the limitations of a mechanic like goad,
you might have lingering subconscious bias that
causes you to feel overly comfortable in the
state of your deck looking at a category of seven
goad cards, and this can be prevented by simply
categorizing cards based on what role they’re
playing instead. In most decks I’d probably
choose defense as the primary task that goad
accomplishes, but in my Malfegor deck I have
Kardur in removal as a primary category, since
a big goal of removal in that deck is to clear
out blockers and buy me time between Malfegor
ETBs, and that’s what Kardur does. Notably,
though, I also have Kardur packaged with my
damaging effects in a secondary category since
he can help with life total pressure as a side
benefit—not the main benefit, but a side benefit.
This logic also applies to a lesser extent with
any other type of deck that uses opposing tools
to win. Some theft commanders give players a
gentle nudge toward proactivity—both Admiral
Beckett Brass and Gonti Canny Acquisitor
require connecting with opposing life
totals to start thieving in the first place,
so your commander is already pushing you to
have your own plan for winning. In other cases,
though, players will make theft the main plan,
and then they’ll simply assume that wincons will
arrive naturally. Surely my Gonti will find me a
tasty card to destroy my opponents with. And
maybe that will happen, but maybe it won’t
as well—quite a lot of ways to win the game are
tied into synergy packages in some form or other,
and whereas the tokens player has a whole
deck full of token generation for their
overrun effects to pump up, you’re over there
putting up some meager imitation of their plan
with the small handful of creatures you’ve
managed to scrounge together. For this reason,
I like to play it safe with these as well. There’s
a decent chance a theft card will find you some
removal or some ramp, maybe even some draw as long
as it’s not tied in deeply with a synergy package.
All three of these things are important, and
having a card that probably gives you access
to some of them can be quite helpful.
But, it’s simply not a reliable plan
for closing out a game, and internalizing
that fact will cause you to win more games.
#2: Your deck isn’t reactive enough
I’ve mentioned this for 13 decks, and this ties
in closely with the last problem. While some decks
overload on defensive or control tools and fail
to spend adequate deck space on their own plan,
other decks do the opposite, under-investing in
ways to deal with opposing gameplans. A natural
question might be “what does under-investing in
interaction look like” and you might be expecting
me to give some magic number, possibly a large
magic number. And you wouldn’t be unreasonable
to assume such a thing—most of my decks
feature 20 or more pieces of interaction.
But, I’ve actually reviewed a number of decks that
feature 8 or 7 or even 5 pieces of interaction,
and where I’m okay with that number. What these
decks have in common is that they are tight on
space and ruthlessly proactive. They have
some bold plan that requires a lot of deck
coordination to set up right, and their deck
is all about making that plan a problem for
their opponents to deal with. And, that is a
valid strategy. If you have a voltron-adjacent
deck that can deliver a lot of beatdown in short
order, you might be able to snuff out a potential
problem player before they play something you
might want to remove. If you have a deck that
creates a lot of life total pressure for the
table, you might be able to get opponents to
an uncomfortably low life total before they can
develop super far, which makes greedy value plays
much more challenging for them to pull off. And
obviously, if you have a deck that can outright
win relatively quickly, there’s all sorts of
late game nonsense you won’t need to remove.
With this in mind, the reason why I so frequently
recommend more interaction to people is because
their decks don’t do any of what I just mentioned.
If you’ve built a standard midrangy thing that
wins on a very average timeline, you need some
ways to slow opposing plans or your chances of
winning go down substantially. Variance exists,
and sometimes opponents will just happen to put
together their gameplan much better than you
can. If that gameplan can be slowed down,
you’re still in it, but without interaction you’re
out. Sure, there will be times when you’re the one
whom the variance gods favor, but there’s a good
chance your opponents will be ready for that with
interaction of their own. Notably, this trend
of slower decks needing more removal continues
all the way down, and also has implications for
what type of interaction works best. If you’re a
faster midrange deck, it might feel good to run
mostly mana efficient 1-for-1 classics like Path
to Exile, Nature’s Claim, and Bitter Triumph,
since you might just need to cut down one or
two opposing threats to stay in the driving seat
of a game. On the other hand, if you’re playing
a deck that’s on the slower end, there’s a good
chance your gameplan will need to be grindier and
care much more about card efficiency. On the most
generic end this could just be cards that remove
more stuff for more mana, but you can also tie
your interaction into your deck’s synergy packages
for increased efficiency. In my Sharuum deck I run
mostly ETB-based interaction, with no conventional
instant or sorcery removal, and this can allow
the deck to outvalue all three opponents at the
same time once it gets fully chugging with its
flicker engine. In this deck’s case this lack of 1
for 1 interaction feels okay, since the slides can
step in as emergency creature removal in a pinch,
but that reduction in contingency removal could be
a counterbalancing force to improved card-for-card
value in some decks. The big picture here is that
you shouldn’t think about your deck’s interaction
as some kind of grim obligation you need to
fulfill so a YouTuber won’t be disappointed
in you. Figure out what your interaction suite is
trying to accomplish for your deck, and treat it
as a part of your deck that’s in a state of
collaboration with your proactive gameplan.
#1: Your deck is unfocused on the
micro level AKA you have dead cards
I have said this about 21 different decks, and
indeed, running cards that will frequently feel
dead in hand is a very common problem
for EDH players. That said, there are
layers to this one. The most pure version of this
relates to synergies that are relatively thin,
so if you put a small lifegain theme or
counters theme or tokens theme into a deck,
some payoff cards for those things are going
to feel kinda useless unless they’re good on
their own or tie into other parts of the deck.
Sometimes this might not even be intentional—God
Pharaoh’s Gift is a fun engine card for decks
that like high-cost artifacts, but without some
combination of a high creature count and ways to
get cards into the graveyard, the card’s stronger
games likely won’t make up for its weaker games
where it struggles to find good exile targets.
Another way dead cards can come up is when we
consider amplifier cards, and other cards whose
effect is based on how well a player is already
doing. To be clear, these aren’t strictly bad,
and they perform an important purpose—they allow
a deck to turn a corner, a tool that leverages
a state of moderate power to create a state of
overwhelming power. A token doubler might turn
a modest token plan into one that’s a genuine
threat, a power-matters card like Traverse the
Outlands can turn a single large creature into a
bunch of extra value, and a damage amplifier like
Fiery Emancipation can turn a mildly threatening
ping plan into an outright win in short order.
The important thing here is that these require
something else to already be happening,
and have no effect in any situation where that’s
not the case. The key thing to look for to figure
out whether these cards will be vital gamepieces
or deadweight is to see how consistently the thing
you’re amplifying will be present and sticking
around. If it’s a very common and/or resilient
part of your gameplan, that’s great! Pack some
of these in. But if it’s a less common or more
fragile part of your gameplan, you’ll want to show
a bit of restraint—lower numbers of the most pure
amplifiers, and more in the way of flexible cards
that help get a gameplan going in the first place.
The exact numbers will still vary person to person
depending on your preferred level of swinginess
and the amount you’re okay with stallouts,
but this general principle applies regardless.
If you want to hear more about dead cards,
I made a whole video about them earlier
this year which will be linked in the
description, and for that exact reason,
I’m going to stop talking about them
now, which concludes this list. But,
if you want to hear about some deckbuilding
mistakes I’ve made this year, you can sign up
for my patreon or a YouTube membership, and
a preview of that video begins right now.